- Good morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one one is believe,
and I believe entrepreneurs
are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today, we're going to learn
how to be your real self
over the UKRS-One.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- If you can be a better you,
success is in the back of that.
I'll say it again.
Make sure you get this, brother,
'cause you all need to
listen to me right now.
Success is based on
you being you.
If you can't be your real self,
success is impossible.
A fake you can never be successful.
Only a real you is going to be successful.
- I 100% agree that you will only have
your real success when
you find your real self
and you apply it and you take action on it
every single day.
You can model, you could copy,
you could learn from others,
to get somewhere faster,
but you will never reach
your true potential by
being a junior version
of somebody else.
I had an entrepreneur
friend of mine reach out,
she started a new business, she was one
of the top trainers at
a gym here hin Canada.
And she wanted to go
teach that training system
to other people, basically
take the training
that she learned from the big corporate
and apply it and help smaller
gyms do their training.
Using that model, all
she would be at best,
is a junior version of the big corporate.
So if somebody, as an example,
studying under Tony Robbins, and goes out
and applies his strategies
to help other people,
if you don't build on it,
if you don't improve on it
then all you're going to be at best
is a junior Tony Robbins.
You're going to be a
poor man's Tony Robbin.
So if somebody can't afford
Tony, they would come to you.
You can be so much more
than a junior version
of somebody else.
And so yes, you model, and
you copy, and you learn
to get ideas, to test,
to try to implement,
and then to tweak and
improve and make your own.
So as an example, when I was working
with my agent and my media trainer,
they would always give
me assignments every week
and say, "Evan, your next
video you have to do this."
Try this, try this, give
me different assignments
and Steve came at it
from a very aggressive,
you've got to raise the stakes, you've got
to make it more important point of view
and Janie came at it
from a more connection,
love and soft point of
view, and they would always
give me assignments.
And every assignment they gave me,
never quite hit, always
felt uncomfortable.
I would do it, I would do it
like they wanted me to do it,
and I never quite fully connected.
It was a stretch, it was better
than what I was currently doing,
but it wasn't quite what I needed.
And I always had to take their advice
and tweak it a little bit,
and build on it, and grow it,
to make it feel right for me.
And so every time you're
learning these strategies
that I'm sharing on this channel,
you're learning from Steve
Jobs, or Oprah Winfrey,
or whoever it is that you look up to
and want to be a huge success,
your goal should never be
to be the next Steve
Jobs or Oprah Winfrey,
your goal is to be the
best version of yourself.
And you do that by modeling others
and learning from them, and
then tweaking the strategies
so that it fits for you.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is one
thing that you've learned
from somebody successful,
or somebody on this channel,
and then tweaked their
strategy to make it work
in your business.
Leave it down on the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Ariel.
Ariel, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really,
really appreciate it
and I really hope you're
enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- What do you want to say to your fans
that ask you like, yo, are
you still going to make
that high BPM, you know, festival music,
to Lee, are you leaving that for more --
- I'm not leaving anything.
- Midstreamer, can you
explain that transition
and what you're doing there?
- For me it's all about
trying to find new sounds,
reinventing your own sound.
I can release 128 BPM
club song every week,
but I don't know, I want
to challenge myself too,
I want to try out new
things, I want to experiment,
and me trying something
new and doing something
like Scared to be Lonely
and In the Name of Love
doesn't mean I'm completely
switching my sound.
In October, I just released seven
very aggressive 128 BPM house songs
and I've got Ultra coming up,
I've got Coachella coming up,
and I'm also going to play a lot of
old sounding Martin Garrix.
It's a weird situation,
because then I released
a house song one year
ago and they're like,
"Oh, same repetitive boring stuff.
"Do something new, be refreshing."
And I do something new and they're like,
"We miss the old Martin Garrix."
And I'm like, wait, what
do you guys want me to do?
But for me, what I
think is most important,
is just me being myself in the studio.
Doing what I want and don't let
other people's opinions affect my music.
I want to represent what I want to make
and I'm not switching my sound,
I'm just having fun.
- I live for the quiet moments
where I can be my most authentic self
and hear myself think.
Somebody asked me, "What makes you happy?"
My husband said, "Bacon."
(audience laughing)
Which is true.
I'm the happiest when I'm
my most authentic self.
When nobody's looking,
when nobody's judging me,
when nobody's leaving nasty
comments on my (mumbles),
and I can just exist.
And in that quiet space, I realized,
I am worthy by birth right.
I am fierce and fabulous
because I breathe.
All of us here in this room,
we are worthy, we are valid.
Our journeys are real and worth while.
And there is nothing that anyone can do
to take that away from us.
Everything terrible
that has happened to us,
we have a choice at how we ought to react.
A lot of times, what
we're actually reacting to
is the fear of humiliation,
the fear of what are they
going to think about me?
The fear of possible judgment.
Newsflash, people will judge you
whether you discover the cure for cancer
or sit on the couch.
You might as well live.
I am a wife,
but that does not define me.
I am an actress, and that as sure as hell
does not define me.
I'm a parent, while awesome,
that is not my whole life.
None of those things,
even though I get a lot
of praise for that, makes me worthy.
I am worthy by birth right,
I am Gabrielle Union Wade.